we will not accept any physical
infrastructure at the border
we won't see the emergence of a hard
border on our island that will be no
hard border we don't want a border no
hard border
to be no hard border on the island of
ireland no matter what happens
different channels see a message but if
neither government is preparing for a
hard border
the dup says there's no need for a
backstop it was very significant when
the irish prime minister
outlined his new deal preparations was
no mention of any border infrastructure
whatsoever so many of us believe this
whole backstop
arrangement is totally unnecessary and
as a political device and
but for that backstop i think we could
move ahead get into the trade talks and
have a withdrawal agreement
so what would happen in a no deal
scenario eu
or world trade organization member
states could demand a border on the
island of ireland
david finnemore lectures in european
politics at queen's university belfast
presidents suggest that the eu will
insist that its internal market is
protected and that would normally
involve the external border existing
so yes i would imagine ireland would
come under pressure as far as the uk is
concerned
i it may not necessarily be the wto that
brings the pressure but it's going to be
other members of the wto who want to
ensure
that the market that they are sending
goods to the uk market
is a market to which if they have
preferential access that access is
generally preferential
the irish government hasn't wavered on
the backstop despite the risk and no
deal brexit poses for ireland
in dublin this is about much more than
customs
for people like me who grew up on the
border may be hard for people
outside of ireland to imagine it's not
just about trade
or goods and services or inspections
like security for immigration
this is fundamentally about people it's
about peace and it's about identity
ireland couldn't accept any deal that
risked a return to a hard border
but the dup couldn't accept one that
risked
northern ireland's position in the
united kingdom and they're wielding
enormous influence at westminster
it was barely mentioned during the
referendum campaign
many people thought dover was the
closest the uk came to the rest of the
eu
but the irish border where northern
ireland meets the republic
on tarmac became the defining issue
so this could be the place where the
prime minister's withdrawal agreement
reaches the end of the road on both
sides of the line
they are keen to hear if theresa may
plans to
push on or take some kind of brexit
detour
david blevins sky news on the irish
border